let's put this story here talking about
culture we got this from Indie wire it's
weirdly hard to read stranger things
Star what's his name Caleb yeah Caleb
it's cut off by the thing McLaughlin
calls out fan racism why am I the least
favorite you feel the bigotry McLaughlin
said sometimes it's hard to talk about
and for people to understand but when I
was younger it definitely affected me a
lot first I want to point out here's
what he said he said why am I the least
favorite have the least amount of
followers he says a part of a deep
conversation I'm on the same show as
everybody from season one
so like the dude
has less followers than his Co co-stars
so he immediately sues his face people
don't like him because he's black
now in that capacity right there I saw
this story and a lot of other people saw
the story and they started saying like
oh this is wokeness this is a problem
and then I read further and I realized
he is 100 correct I believe the reason
he has less followers is because many
fans of the show are in fact racist and
he hit the nail on that with the hammer
and you know what you want to know what
what's missing from the context in this
conversation he says sometimes overseas
you feel the racism you feel the bigotry
sometimes it's hard to talk about and
for people to understand but when I was
younger it definitely affected me a lot
that's right outside of the United
States there's probably a lot of people
who won't follow them because they are
racist you take a look at what happened
with Star Wars in China and they took
the dude who played Finn off the cover
where they shrink him or something or
put him in a helmet they put him in a
helmet they put him in a helmet because
they were like people in China are very
very racist and they don't want to see
this and so the Disney as a corporation
was like yeah we're totally fine with
that that to me is insane but this
dude's seemingly not talking about
people in America he's saying like I got
less followers than them yeah it's
probably people in China and other
countries that would watch stranger
things but are racist
so there you go man you know Amman is uh
um Instagram page right now it doesn't
look like he he posts a lot and he
already as of now has 15.4 million
followers why does he have more
followers than words than me
speak Express people
possible explanation
oh my God that's it I can't believe only
15 million people would follow him
that's 15.4 unreal yes on Instagram he's
one of the most famous people in the
world and he's like he's like man people
overseas don't like me as much as my
other cast members and he's not that
actor what a victim like he he posted on
July 30th September 9th isn't that
September 12th September 16th September
18th and that's it that's all the posts
wait did he maybe he deleted some or
something so this is inadvertently
making the case that America is in fact
the greatest country on Earth we're more
enlightened exactly but that's why
people don't want you to like real so if
you're saying that America is an
inherently racist country can you find
me one that isn't exactly that's a good
question
well if America is the least racist
country but it is racist then every
country is substantially worse and more
racist there you go
uh bingo you got it that's that's it but
you're not allowed to say that so this
show is shut down and
that'll be it you know America is a
great place yeah that's why everybody
desperately wants to be here correct and
then you know what's funny is we're
seeing these videos there's a video that
went viral that uh jackposovic was
sharing about this like white woman and
she's like hi everybody I moved on to
Guatemala to be part of a sustainable
living community and then she's like
spinning and like there's like there's
an active volcano and then I saw that
and I was like is this why woke people
don't like white people because like
it's it's a really annoying thing to
have these like hippie man bun you know
uh like elitists be like I'm gonna move
down to Guatemala to teach the poor
people and it's just like yeah is that
what you were talking about because that
because I gotta I gotta agree that is
annoying for these people to do but it's
funny because you have white people
leaving the US going to Mexico and going
to Central America at the same time you
have people from Central America trying
to come to the United States so as you
just you know it's kind of funny how
that works huh
you know I I just can't stop thinking
about this this kid he wants to be a
victim so bad he's a millionaire
he's on a hit series
15.4 million people follow them and yet
he's he's like it's not enough like he
he you really need to I mean you know
it's it's a it's a quote from an article
you know maybe there's more to this kid
but you know Caleb if you're listening
just appreciate what you have you know
and don't don't get caught up in the
numbers yeah don't get caught up in what
you don't have and and how other people
think about you appreciate the fact that
15.4 million kids uh like you and love
you and that you're a millionaire and
you're probably set for life that you
could reach out to and have a positive
impact on by promoting personal
responsibility good values good morals
and you could lead as an example of
something good rather than of course
just concentrating on something that
that is negative and and I think there
is an aspect of society promoting
victimization uh promoting as you
mentioned Andrew this larger idea hey
I'm the victim here and now you have to
really like my stuff on social media and
the algorithms promote that stuff and I
think it's it's disgusting I think it
should be pushed back on because in in
reality like we're some of the most
privileged one of the richest people on
the face of the world just by simply
living here in the United States we're
so freaking
than human history yeah yeah in human
history so freaking lucky everything at
our fingertips and if you want something
go out there and get it there shouldn't
be anything standing in your way but
that's hard I just looked up
I looked at the network of this the cast
of stranger things the first thing I
want to say is these like celebrity net
worth websites are just very wrong like
oh yeah of course one of them said like
Ian was worth like five million dollars
or whatever and we were all kind of like
10 million but but no we were kind of
like maybe there's something we're not
graphing he's got those yeah I mean he's
a co-founder of mines and mines is worth
a lot so like maybe it wasn't wrong but
I'm like I'm pretty sure this stuff's
not true but anyway it says that Caleb
McLaughlin's net worth is four million
dollars and there's
um there's another person let me let me
pull this back up whose net worth is
only one million dollars I think it's
one I think is it is it Maya are all
those like AI generated websites that
are no this is a different one this is
Netflix life okay but it did look at
those websites and then compile them but
uh let's see Joe here is 4 million
Charlie Heaton's five million I mean
okay here you go Sadie's sink is worth a
million bucks but she's new right she's
right yeah but so so anyway my point is
I don't know what their net worth
actually is but I'm pretty sure everyone
on this show is a millionaire and so
there is something special about a group
of millionaires and the not even the
lowest millionaires complaining about
not having enough and there's just
something where it's like
I don't I don't know how I'm supposed to
feel about that you know what I mean
like it's a big group of ultra rich
people on a very successful and popular
show and one dude's like I'm the least
favorite it's not okay and it's like
well you're still like literally in the
top thousand richest people on the
planet or something like that I mean how
many millions
there shouldn't even be a news story
it's like oh well people overseas don't
like me so much okay and that's it like
wow but he he does mention that people
wouldn't get in line for him at
Comic-Con some people didn't stand in my
line because I was black some people
told me I don't want to be in your line
because you are mean to 11. how does
this happen right I mean like no I mean
this for real like did somebody come to
him and tell him that just like say
racist things to him
they wouldn't get in like I mean what's
what's the proof oh but I mean it makes
tons of sense somebody gets in line they
wait for 20 minutes and they get up to
him and say he's gonna let you know like
me and my friends you know didn't want
to get in line because of your race
right do you remember that BYU story
from a couple weeks ago no we're talking
about player yeah yeah and it was like
that got a ton of clicks and then the
you know the real story
is like that nobody wants to hear that
so I think that's the point is like Hey
how do you you know keep yourself
relevant how do you get in the headlines
well just why don't you go say something
controversial that's going to get both
sides to click on these websites and to
talk about you and follow you on social
media yeah and this worked they were
like yeah oh yo he's gonna absolutely
get sympathy subscribers you know it's
like oh you know I really like him and I
should have probably followed him I
don't want to be a racist so I'm gonna
like I'm gonna like click follow on this
guy uh but he's he's like a b-list actor
he's not like he I mean when you compare
him to Finn wolfhard or Millie Bobby
Brown I mean they're like the the
breakout stars of that show he's not and
and it's maybe it's because of his
character the way it's written or
whatever but it's like if you go to
Comic-Con like there's not a lot of time
you have to you have to look at the list
and see the agenda like who's gonna be
there and you kind of map out and go
okay I really want to meet this person I
want to meet this person and he wouldn't
like if I was a kid if I was a stranger
fan I I don't know if he'd be in my top
20 honestly here's what I'll say about
stranger things though mad respect for
something original yeah it is original
they're still there from the Montauk
project no I know but
moment he's right Richie is absolutely
right right the monster project was
written what like 93 or something let me
say um this this one yeah let me see it
let's see what's the Year this is I
think the second one was written
somewhere in there 89 or something it
was 92. 92 I was close that was close
and again nothing wrong I'm I have
nothing against this kid I don't know
anything about his personal life but you
know he's he's not one of the breakout
stars of the show the Montauk project is
fake news you know and it's made to look
real and it's very it's very clever and
very well done but my understanding is
it's a total fiction and I did a bunch
of research into it a while I'm gonna
have to have a debate on this sometimes
it looks like a Mark Dice book so I did
a bunch of I did a bunch of research
into it and it's like considered to be
the the the story behind it is that they
wanted to make a book that overlapped
with reality and it would sell better
and be marketed as something real but it
was just like a function who Preston
nickels I don't know I don't know that's
what I read but uh so maybe it's not
true maybe maybe it's all right you can
watch interviews with this guy Preston
Nichols I mean he's he's a Nutty dude
but he definitely knows like radios and
frequencies and all that stuff and when
he talks about how he participated in
this project what do you like cross
diagrams and like my point is stranger
things is inspired by the Montauk
project but it's like an original
concept with like characters and you
know the upside down the the reality I I
appreciate it man yeah I agree I think
the show's bad you know the last season
was just miserably terrible but I like
it because they're doing something new
you know like what do we got now we got
a prequel of Game of Thrones a prequel
of Lord of the Rings we get more Marvel
derivative garbage and it's just like
okay
what you know when it all started when
because I think 1997 was Seven Years in
Tibet and they banned that movie from
China and I think it was MGM that
produced it they'd lost hundreds of
millions of dollars and after that it
was like a message to Hollywood like yo
our Market's huge and it better appeal
to us as well as the American audience
as well as you know so now it's a global
market that you're that you're going for
so that's an argument for making new
things not for regurgitating no because
it has to be homogenized to the point
where you know it's going to work across
a broad population which makes sense
that you could write something new to
work across because then you don't know
how it's going to do you're like
Transformers 67 did great so let's just
do 68 and 16 of course but that's not
that's not let's put a Chinese actress
in there to appeal to China so we can
get like that like how do the Chinese
feel about this new idea they're like
Shang Chi was very obviously alike they
were trying to break into the Chinese
market because the movie had no reason
to be in San Francisco at all you guys
see it I don't watch Chinese it whatever
that's like all of Hollywood though yeah
exactly but it was like you wonder why
it is this guy was in San Francisco at
all it's like the story is very much set
around China and then the main character
is like I'm in San Francisco now for
some reason and now we're going back to
China and they go to like portal to
another reality with like you know
pandas or something
and then there's like that's what they
did with Doctor Strange too right they
changed the Tibetan character yeah that
was so this is really funny I know you
have to watch the core and yeah I do so
so before it's got a lot of work cut off
yeah so there's this meme going around
because of the aerial thing where they
made the Aerials portrayed by a black
actress and so they uh there's a meme
where it's a bunch of non-white
characters that were played by white
actors and they were like no one cared
no one cared no one cared and then it
shows the the screaming woe Jack when it
shows Ariel and they're like the meme
basically says like nobody cares when
white actors play characters of color
and it showed the ancient one in the
comic Tibetan guy and then it showed uh
till the Swinton and then I had to tell
people like whenever I see the meme I'm
like actually the fans were really upset
that they got a white woman to play that
because the reason they got rid of the
ancient one was not because of racism
was because they were trying to appease
China and China didn't want a Tibetan
guy and so everyone everyone else is
like there you go oh that actually makes
sense why like okay so what you mean the
fans really were mad about that yeah
like but like while you're explaining
that they tuned into like the next Tick
Tock video and they're like wait what'd
you say sorry I didn't hear that and
then they started doing a weird name
dance and then in China they'd ban that
stuff but they always complain about uh
like oh you know
for they always say that all people are
racist if you you know you gender swap
or if you uh race swapping nobody cares
like Sam Jackson as Nick Fury where was
the outrage there well Robert Downey Jr
dude Robert Downey Jr
he's still he's he's not a fury in the
comics he did uh was made black a long
time Tropic Thunder but he but he was
white originally and I think and the
same thing with the the Fantastic Four I
hear that they're that they're looking
to possibly make it an all-black cast
when uh when the last Fantastic Four
they had
I just walked out Johnny Johnny Storm
with Michael B Jordan right but but I
think the uh the latest news on
Fantastic Fours they're going to get um
uh what's her name Daddario and her
brother Alexandra Daddario is that her
name but I don't know whatever but her
and her brother are going to play Susan
storm that's what that's what the rumor
is so you know whatever uh what's that
guy's name John Krasinski he's yeah okay
I think he did he did he did great as
read Richards but I guess they're not
going to use him I don't know I kind of
feel like it looks great it it he looks
he looks like I know Reed Richards but
he's a he's a good character anyway he's
a good actor but I I gotta be honest I
think the MCU is just completely done
it's just become regurgitated derivative
garbage at this point it had something
unique when they were like re
reinvigorating these stories like Iron
Man and Captain America and Thor and I
think end game was the end game I think
after that it's just been like
like black widow is awful oh yeah I mean
it was there's uh I can't remember who
did it I'm really sorry but there was
there's there's like a it feels like
it's a five hour breakdown of this movie
showing every tiny little thing that's
wrong with it and it's it's Brian I
can't remember who did it uh but I
watched the the last Spider-Man movie
and I've kind of given up like I didn't
I didn't think about uh watching Thor I
didn't watch Doctor Strange I'm sorry I
was never gonna watch She-Hulk uh well
they're not telling Original Stories
they're not
here's I like doctor strange it's a
movie it's an origin story it's a guy's
doing his thing sure Doctor Strange
Doctor Strange two is Avengers
like Thor Avengers it's all just
Avengers now it's all like here's 27
characters all dancing on stage it's
just more of a video game than a movie
like how much of that movie is CGI
versus like you look at the budget and
then you look at the credits and there's
like 20 actors and like 600 animators
and the only reason I would actually
watch it is because it's Sam Raimi
directing but that's it thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there